welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a review of thor love
and thunder a spoiler-free analysis of
the film's deeper meaning its impact on
the brighter mcu its general enjoyment
relative to thor ragnarok and other
marvel movies and how fun those goats
are a while ago i did share my
post-screening reaction but that was
really a babbling rant about how i cried
and how not enough of you know me well
enough to know why i cried so now after
some more time has passed i've been able
to collect my thoughts anyway that still
will not spoil the film swat so first
general thoughts thor love and thunder
is an invigorating adrenaline boost to
the heart as a hilarious action brom-com
fueled by taika with tt's stylistic
irreverence with deeper thematic
ambition that seeks to build worlds of
meaning in the mcu where ragnarok sought
to burn them down christian bale as gore
is my favorite mcu villain since thanos
this actor finally allowed to take the
reigns in a superhero title the way
heath ledger stole his show back in the
dark knight and bale drags us into a
shadowy hell with a haunting physical
performance akin to his macabre delight
in american psycho but this time
motivated by heartbreaking grief love
and thunder is the greatest romance we
have seen in an mcu film but not just as
a romantic tragic comedy between thor
and his ex-girlfriend jane foster
well you're right but the chemistry
burns equally in the hearts of all
characters of this ensemble valkyrie
chord even stormbreaker all of these
supporting players get their own fully
formed arcs when comparing it to other
marvel phase 4 movies i expect many
marvel fans will rank love and thunder
below spiderman no at home but above dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
because while it may not give the
average new rockstar subscriber
everything you want from an mcu event
this remains a deeply satisfying
mythological adventure with meaty action
sexy team-ups and visually stunning set
pieces this is the deepest i have felt
about these characters why tt has
achieved as much character development
in under two hours as marvel normally
spends six episodes of a disney plus
series exploring natalie portman and
chris hemsworth finally reached that
chemistry that i've been waiting to see
these two actors have in the several
films we've seen them together in and
while you may not root for them as hard
as you do say wanda envision or loki and
silvi i suspect this movie will break
your heart also i don't think it's
necessarily fair to compare these films
to loki or juan division but either way
marvel studios keeps surprising me with
their ability to however large the
screen these stories are told on make us
believe in these characters as something
more than merch surprise [ __ ]
but really as mortals and immortals
questioning their own beliefs sometimes
worrying about the fate of these
characters can get you so stressed out
you just want to pull your hair out but
if you are the kind of guy worried about
losing your hair in the more natural
unfortunate way well our friends at
keeps can help you out because two out
of three guys will experience some form
of male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 with keeps you can get
quality expert care without ever
visiting a doctor's office or a pharmacy
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy though you never have to
go into a doctor's office keeps has a
network of expert medical advisors
prescribers and care specialists who
support you in making your hair goals a
reality easily subscribe to keeps and
get refill reminders so you'll never run
low on the products you need to take
care of your hair hair loss stops with
keeps to get 50 off your first order go
to keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars now the top
question in mind the fans going into
this will be how thor love and thunder
compares to thor ragnarok astaika tt
truly did reset many aspects of thor's
corner of this universe back in 2017 for
those who felt that thor ragnarok might
have allowed taekwo titu to take a torch
to too much of the mcu killing off the
warriors 3 and obliterating one of the
few interesting off-world settings in
the mcu as a punch line and the deaths
of characters like odin and scourge not
bearing enough emotional weight hey i
have good news love and thunder shows a
more mature watiti who makes you feel
every gut punch and when it comes to
world building erects as much as
possible crazy and intentional from the
way it evolves new asgard into a truly
satirical escapist fantasy on earth too
turning out new cool to look at horizons
like omnipotent city in the shadow realm
labels that are used in the marketing so
it's not spoiling too much to name them
don't worry two other backdrops and
imagery that i cannot wait to discuss in
future videos not gonna go into it here
because it is a spoiler i'm just gonna
say shocked to see some of this stuff in
live action and i'm not quite sure how
they pulled it off all this is saying
that love and thunder just gives more
gifts to the mcu for future titles
compared to thor ragnarok which really
when we're honest played with existing
toys and just broke them a process that
was very fun to watch however if what
you loved about thor ragnarok was its
second act the team up with hulk on
sakhar in the introductions of valkyrie
and korg and the grand master i can't
say love and thunder lives up to that
madcap fever dream in douglas adamson
absurdism i promise you omnipotent city
will delight you in plenty of other ways
but it's just not as hot of a party as
goldblum's gladiator trash planet still
as a tiger with tt character comedy it
is as funny as ragnarok is i think i
laughed even more but you know i also
have a thing for screaming goats and
shitty gods and petty inanimate objects
and compared to ragnarok love and
thunder is certainly prettier to look at
with high contrast black and white
photography not just for show but to
express the inner depravity of the
warriors hats off to director of
photography barry bazz ideon production
designer nigel phelps and of course the
creators of the comics that this story
was very much based on god of thunder
and the mighty thor by jason aaron and
issa ribic who created some of this
movie's gorgeous imagery adapted almost
exactly from the pages of the comics now
how well does this work as an mcu event
now again i'm not gonna go into spoilers
here but love and thunder makes you
appreciate mcu past with delightful
easter eggs and call-backs and cameos
but more importantly makes you ponder
the future of this universe alongside
titles like doctor strange ii and moon
knight ms marvel black panther what kind
of forever all of these to different
extents spiritual morality plays that
consider the souls of marvel heroes the
infinity saga asked who marvel heroes
would be fighting now phase 4 seems to
be asking why and for whom what was once
abstract now has a pulse and i cannot
wait to see where marvel goes with this
now i understand marvel titles feel the
need to revert to a status quo by the
ends of their stories but marvel has
always been at its best i think when
battles truly warp their worlds and
paint themselves into narrative corners
captain america winter soldier thor
ragnarok infinity war end game loki
spider-man no way home all of these
titles kill their darlings and leave us
hungry for the next installment so in
that regard love and thunder may leave
your tummy rumbling a bit the way it did
after some other marvel titles like
great but did anything really change
were any prices paid this is all really
fun but are we left with anything new
that we're excited about as answers to
those questions your mileage may vary
but i'll tell you for me
yes especially as this movie's final
moments define precisely what love and
thunder means and i'll tell you if you
have someone in your life that you love
someone known to you currently or just
someone that your heart seeks still you
may tear up here i spend the credits
sobbing trust me when you go see this
movie try to bring someone whose eyes
you can look into or just a friend from
work now to talk about where this film
falls a bit short we must
blaspheme and critique take away titi's
filmmaking style now i'm saying all this
as a massive fan of watiti and
everything this guy has made boy hunt
for the wilder people what we do in the
shadows jojo rabbit ragnarok our flag
means death the man is a genius and i
will watch everything he makes but love
it or not we gotta admit taika takeaway
tt has a tendency to paint every
narrative beat with the same brush of
ironic detachment even moments that we
really should be terrified that the
heroes will fail or grieving loss but
when you're watching the tt joint it's
really like a stick shift from laughing
to hell yeah to once per movie cry and
then not much else in between those
harder to quantify feelings like
depression or anxiety or just raw ugly
panic really framed through waititi's
lens as objective matt does the fact
that we're processing at the distance so
we could best officially move past them
rather than actually feel them and never
ever ever embrace those sloppy sobs or
beer guts i know that may sound a little
unfair i'm just saying this movie laughs
through a lot of beats that i kind of
just wanted to feel for a second this
might come from waititi's ingenuity
coming from his improvisation and as a
junkie for improv comedy myself a note i
often hear is rather than trying to joke
your way out of something just consider
slowing down and taking a beat to scream
or panic or agonize and trust me the
audience will jump off a cliff with you
comedians are often afraid to go to
those dark places and in this movie
sometimes you just want the characters
in love and thunder to scream louder
than the goats do or better yet ask why
the goats are screaming because as
someone living in 2022 i can relate with
someone who only communicates with
existential dread all that said taiko tt
clearly does not need my stupid improv
notes i love this film both as a marvel
nerd and as someone who just loves
heartfelt action movies and nudity aside
this is a family film you will be
shocked at how much of a family movie
love and thunder is i'm not gonna give
this any numerical score other than zero
out of ten mephisto's which is how i
have ranked every marvel title but
technically he might have shown up in
omnipotent city i didn't really see him
but then again you never see him you
just feel him inside you phrasing
intentional i cannot wait to hear what
you think about thor love and thunder
we're gonna have lots of videos coming
out this week about it so be sure to
subscribe to new rockstars you can also
follow new rocks on social media you can
follow me on social media on instagram
and twitter avos and again subscribe to
this channel for more announcements of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you